bonjour à toutes et à tous bonjour jimmy
et bonjour marie france coule
bonjour monsieur caruge à bonjour aux
auditeurs et aux auditrices de martin et
la première merci donc d'être présente
dans le studio ce matin vous êtes
deuxième vice présidente de l'assemblée
de martinique président du aussi du
comité de bassin et de l'environnement
voilà de l'eau la biodiversité c'est sa
nouvelle appellation gens donnent mal
d'ailleurs à la retenir cette
appellation mais vous avez bien fait de
corriger de préciser mais on vous reçoit
ce matin marie france tout comme
secrétaire générale adjointe du parti
politique le rdm le rassemblement des
démocrates martinique alors dans la
période spéciale que nous vivons
marie-france tout laisse que le rdm va
effectuer une rentrée de rentrée
politique là ces jours ci et puis est ce
qu'il est déjà en ordre de bataille pour
les prochaines élections
les prochaines territoriales en mars
prochain et après des municipales qui
peut être vous l'estimez ne sont pas
trop mal passé pour pour le rdm on peut
peut-être commencer par la rappeler un
peu ce qui s'est passé là en mars
dernier pour votre parti alors je vais
dans un premier temps on corriger un
petit peu notre reprendre l'appellation
de notre parti c'est bien le rdm
rassemblement démocratique pour la
martinique et le possédons l'idée de
servir être au service de la martinique
donc ce n'est pas les démocrates
martiniquais comme vous l'avez dit donc
bien a simplement démocratique pour la
martinique
effectivement nous revenons des
élections municipales qui ont eu lieu il
y a quelques mois et nous avons tout
lieu nous ndm d'être satisfait des
résultats que nous avons eues puisque
nous avons pu maintenir nous sommes
maintenus dans la commune d installer
avec le camarade eugène d'un lent chez
nous avons pu conquérir une nouvelle
municipalité celle du diamant avec tout
jeune élu
une guide tous et qui est militant et un
dm aussi lui aussi depuis de nombreuses
années peut-être un peu discret mais
toujours présent dans le parti et puis
nous avons tout lieu également de nous
satisfaire des bons résultats que nous
avons eues au zoo au carbet avec louis
georges griffith qui a mené une très
belle bataille a fait un très bon
résultat mais qui depuis quelques années
fait un travail de fond dans cette
commune et dans l'idée effectivement de
porter très haut les valeurs du rdm
notamment tout ce qui concerne la
démocratie est également nous avons eu
un très beau résultat on doit aussi le
souligner a assez pierre avec luminale
arabe qui est une jeune femme et nous
avons donc pour le ndm cette volonté de
mettre en avant de nouveaux élus deux
jeunes élus comme je vous le dis vous
toussez mais aussi griffith et puis
aussi les femmes donc nous attendons
toute notre place dans sur l'échiquier
martiniquais alors du coup est ce que le
rassemblement démocratique pour la
martinique puisque c'est l'appellation
exacte est ce qu'ils les prêts est ce
qu'il est en ordre de bataille
est ce que vous pensez vous préparer les
élections territoriales
alors ces résultats comme je voulais
dire nous conforte dans le fait que le
ndm et un parti avec lequel il faut
compter un parti qui a pris toute sa
place sur l'échiquier politique
martiniquais et fort de ces résultats
mais nous sommes justement dans ce
travail de mise en ondes de mise en
marche du parti nous sommes sur le
terrain nous aujourd'hui nous avons
plusieurs on rencontre pour pouvoir re
dynamiser les sections rencontrer les
sections mais aussi les militants nous
avons donc payé ans nous étions au
diamant la semaine dernière nous étions
à saint joseph ce sont des réunions qui
se font sur l'ensemble des territoires
du nord au sud de la martinique il ya un
grand rendez vous de prévu la prochains
jours et justement nous sommes dans
cette dynamique de faire une
mobilisation générale pour bien montrer
que nous ayons des iem il va falloir
compter sur nous pour les prochaines
échéances
mais aussi que nous avons aussi cette
volonté de mettre en a
vont toujours plus nos valeurs et de
lépante est de plus en plus haut donc
oui nous sommes mobilisés oui nous
sommes sur le terrai et oui il faudra
compter avec nous pour les prochaines
élections
alors faut-il le rappeler le secrétaire
général du rassemblement démocratique
pour la martinique
le rdmc claude lise le président de
l'assemblée de martinique qui s'est un
petit peu
dix ont opposé certains pourraient même
dire affronter avec le président du
conseil exécutif
alors il est soutenu le président lise
par une grande partie de son assemblée
donc ça crée un contexte quand même
particulier bon est ce que les choses
vont s'améliorer dans 10 6 7 mois
puisque c'est à peu près dans cette
échéance là qui aura les élections
territoriales
quel regard que vous portez justement
sur ce qui s'est passé ces derniers mois
au sein de la ctm de la gouvernance de
la ctm la secrétaire général claude lise
comme l'ensemble des élus du rdr
nous sommes des personnes de parole nous
avons pris un engagement non seulement
envers les différents partis qui ont
composé ce comment dirais je sais tu ce
rassemblement elle ce rassemblement et
nous tenons vraiment à aller jusqu'au
bout de cet engagement
nous nous sommes engagés aussi envers la
population et c'est parce que nous nous
sommes engagés envers la population à
mettre en place c'est justement un
programme projets dans des conditions
bien précises et on parle souvent du
contrat de gestion monde oublie aussi
que nous avions nous lé mdm contrat avec
le lait le mime qui nous normalement
nous devait nous permettre d'avoir un
certain nombre de responsabilités
notamment le président de l'assemblée il
était prévu qu'il prenne toute sa place
avec tessa dans cette ville
normalement prendre toute sa part et on
a bien vu on a bien vu aujourd'hui que
cette part de responsabilité qui devait
être confiée au président de l'assemblée
pour pouvoir faire aboutir le projet n'a
pas été respecté donc il nous
appartenait et c'est ce que le président
de l'assemblée a fait de pouvoir
remonter au créneau de pointer du doigt
les dysfonctionnements
parce que nous avons si cette
responsabilité vis-à-vis de la
population de bien mettre en avant le
pourquoi des difficultés et si nous
constatons un moment ou un autre que le
projet ne peut pas se mettre en place
mais il est de notre devoir est de le
pointer du doigt donc c'est ce que nous
avons fait très bien donc la méthode la
la la la façon de gouverner c'est un
sujet au rdmc de temps mais aujourd'hui
nous pointons du doigt ce cette
gouvernance que nous déplorons avec une
gouvernance et un pouvoir recentrer
centre est dans les mains d'un seul
surtout concentrés dans les mains d'un
seul homme avec un manque de démocratie
et c'est vrai que nous sommes tous
conscients que quel que soit le projet
que l'on peut avoir si nous n'avons pas
cette part de démocratie eh bien on voit
bien les difficultés de mettre en place
le projet donc vous voulez du changement
on l'a compris au moins à ce niveau là
mise à part ça quels sont les thèmes qui
guident un petit peu la préparation
programmatique justement du rdm pour les
prochaines élections à la ctm
aujourd'hui comme je vous l'aï dit nous
sommes dans une démarche de réflexion de
rencontres avec les acteurs économiques
de rencontres avec nos militants avec
notre base
mais il ya des priorités qui se dégage
c'est vrai évidemment il y lit a très
certainement delhi a des priorités mais
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
co-construction avec l'ensemble des
acteurs avec l'ensemble de la population
le secrétaire général claude lise
rencontre régulièrement des acteurs
économiques un mois également
enfin tous les élus du rdr nous sommes
dans cette démarche vous faites des
consultations citoyennes c'est un peu ce
terme peut vous aider nous sommes sur le
terrain nous sommes nous étions quand b
nous étions assez joseph
mais ce qui selon engagement des gens et
déjà que nous pouvons prendre vis-à-vis
de la population
c'est vraiment de faire en sorte que la
prochaine collectivité soit une telle
activité plus démocratique avec respect
de tous les éleveurs des instants avec
qui parce que vous savez citer quelques
résultats effectivement électoraux lors
municipal mais évidemment le rdr ne peut
pas gagner tout seul gouvernance je
crois qu'aujourd'hui
conscient il vous faudra trouver des
partenaires qui ne peuvent grille même
d'autres qui ne peuvent gagner tout seul
aujourd'hui dans et déjà et je crois que
très clairement nous l'avons bien que
nous n'allons pas en reconduire que nous
n'allons pas en reconduire les choses
telles qu'elles aient un bon on a fait
une première expérience qui s'est avérée
douloureuse qui a fait ce qu'elle sait
mais nous sommes là pour tirer aussi les
conséquences d'une telle alliance est
fort de cette deux sets de 7-6 cette
analyse fort de tout ce que nous avons
pu faire comme entre nous en commun
réflexion nous sommes convaincus qu'il
nous faudra nous et en des iem d'abord
rassemblés au sein de notre un autre
c'est mais aussi rassembler avec
d'autres partenaires qui partagent
véritablement les mêmes valeurs que nous
et c'est dans cet état d'esprit que nous
sommes aujourd'hui en train de faire un
certain nombre de démarches et de de
consulter donc aujourd'hui nous
échangeons ni discutons avec tous mais
en rien n'est encore figé n'est encore
il nous reste une minute alors je vais
rappeler vous êtes partie prenante en
quelque sorte du dossier de lure
martinique alors ce dossier est ce qu'il
n'est pas justement emblématique de ce
qui devrait changer dans la pratique
politique de manière globale chez nous
quoi avec les multi bons partenaires on
l'a vu on le sait l'état bon là c'est m
normalement pas autant que les
communautés d'agglomération mais
malheureusement yade et à la symbolique
de séguinaud la ctm liée enfin voilà
est-ce que ce ce dossier de l'eau vous
allez en faire vous même ou rdm quelque
chose d'assez emblématique et dire ben
voilà précisément c'est ce qu'on
voudrait changer
je crois que nous n'aurons pas dans une
minute le temps de développer le dossier
de l'eau qui est un dossier très
complexe ce que nous pouvons dire c'est
que rdm nous sommes vraiment peau comme
nous puissions aller vers cette instance
unique cette entité unique de l'eau donc
là aussi c'est une bataille fort c'est
un engagement fort tout en sachant qu
nous n'avons pas nous au niveau de la
collectivité cette compétence mais nous
allons accompagner et nous souhaitons
faire ensemble que nous puissions
avancer dans ce sens saint claude lise
qui est également président de l'office
de l'eau et moi même en tant que
président du comité de l'eau et de la
biodiversité nous rencontrons les
différents acteurs de l'eau et nous nous
travaillons justement dans ce sens
nous travaillons également dans le sens
de meilleurs échanges et de meilleur
dialogue entre les différents
partenaires notamment entre les
différentes collectivités qui ont la
compétence eau ou qui y ont un moment où
notre une responsabilité dans ce domaine
donc oui nous nous engageons nous au
niveau de rdm à faire en sorte que nous
allions vers une meilleure gestion du
rhin de loup et bien aller pour terminer
marie-france tout le vous même à titre
personnel la citoyenne marie-france tous
là telle envie voir peut-être même
davantage l'entousiasme pour rempiler si
je puis dire si je peux utiliser cette
expression en tout cas faire partie
d'une nouvelle mandature à cette
collectivité territoriale alors je suis
une militante j'ai effectivement
secondes je suis une militante donc je
serai dans la bataille pour la
collectivité territoriale je serai dans
la campagne d'aidé des élections pour
être probablement sur la liste alors sur
la lys à nous avons effectivement des
instances à qui décide de cela
maintenant il faut aussi que moi même
mais vous allez cuisse mais je suis
prête pour mener la bataille
je suis prête pour mener la bataille
merci marie france tools bonne journée
[Musique]